the question was you know this thing
here the the sort of overall mental
strategy I was suggesting which is move
everything over to one side you may have
noticed I talked it through with you but
I was very conscious of not writing it
down right I didn't actually say god is
greater than or equal to zero
and I've even written it here just so
that you can see what I mean here is why
you cannot begin with this statement and
this is a very common error for people
to make because they do not understand
the way mathematical deductive logic
works you can't make this statement is
like your first line of working because
you don't know that this is true that's
the point of the question you're trying
to prove that it's true this is not an
established fact that you can apply
logic to I like this being an
established fact which you can apply
logic to and then you can get to the
answer okay so you can't begin with this
statement in fact the first time that I
actually write something like this is
like right at the very end after doing
all of this like algebraic legwork okay
so when you see a question gives you a
result like say this okay you can't say
oh well here's a result I'm now going to
start doing some stuff from left to
right hand side of this as if this were
true because you do not know that it's
true yet okay so that's why I put this
in big red letters can't begin with this
you can think it but you can't get to it
to the end okay here's the actual
question I've written down RTP here
which is just my abbreviation for
required to prove just to highlight the
fact that I just said I don't know that
this is true yet me writing it down
doesn't mean I think it's true be
writing it down means okay I need to get
this down so that I can apply some logic
to it so what strategies shall I attempt
just like in earlier problems like
saying that one the first thing I'm
going to do is try and pare this down to
size this number here I think it's one
of those numbers that makes you
calculate a break right I don't know
what to do with this okay so this what
I'm just going to think about this guy
over here for a little while I'm just
going to consider the left-hand side
okay
the left-hand side reminds me a lot of
the work we did with fuse in sequences
it's not a series or a sequence you're
not adding things up your mole
applying them but I can apply some of
the logic that I used back there for
instance this is a very very logical set
of numbers right when the order there
you can see you can predict exactly
what's going to be there and in fact you
can use a trick that we learn from our
little boy Gauss when he was asked to
add up the numbers 1 to 100 remember
what he did sorry 1 to 51 100 that was
one to 100 right
he was like 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 all
the way up to 99 100 doing them in order
that's like a chips way of doing things
ok I'll take me forever
he knows the pattern if you look at it
from both ends he said if you pair up
numbers if you pair up numbers if you
pair up numbers like so I'm even going
to write it right I should be able to
notice there's some logic here that I
can take advantage on okay now when you
pair in this way
think carefully what do you get to what
will be in the middle the numbers are a
little bit large so it's kind of tricky
think to an example that you know that's
easy I'm sorry there's an odd number of
terms here do you agree an odd number so
I'm going to think of a simple example
with an odd number of terms how about
this so if I had that if that was my
product right and I did my pairing whew
you'd pair up these guys then you'd pair
up these guys and then you end up with a
middle term ok and it's easy to see what
would be a quicker way to get to the
middle term without having to do this 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8
how could I go directly there if I had
like an obscene number of turns out what
I do to get to 3 quickly ok so one of
the ways and in what those ways is I
could add 1 to this to turn it into an
even number 6 and then divide by 2
because I'm having aren't I okay since
everything is paired up so if I add 1 to
this that gives me 1996 when you divide
that by 2 you get 998 that's suspicious
right ok now 998 will be the
very very last term it on its own it
doesn't pair with anyone so therefore by
that logic what are the two on either
side what are the numbers that are going
to appear before that one will be
smaller and the other one will be bigger
okay good so what we've done excuse me
is we've broken up this some long
product into a bunch of pairs that are
easier to deal with okay now I'm going
to use some logic from the immediately
previous example that I showed you okay
have a look at this this is telling us
here telling us here that the square
root of a product squared of product is
always less than or equal to this thing
over here okay well if you go back again
another example you can see from this I
could square both sides like that and
that would be less than this do you
agree that's that's okay now how does
this in particular this that's a product
relate to this if I said let's call this
guy a and this B okay then a B a B is
less than or equal to a plus B on to or
squared well what is a plus B onto all
squared in this case for this a and this
B 1 times 1 1 9 5 it's less than or
equal to what have a look we just did
this didn't we it's like we literally
did exactly this is 16 a suggestion I I
took a number I added 1 and I divided it
by 2
yes so this little product here this
pair is going to be less than or equal
to that is 998 how's your brain going do
you see what I'm trying to do here and
you see how this does connect us to this
oh I've got powers of 998 that looks
helpful when you look at the next one
over
it doesn't take you long to realize that
having this pairing up thing is super
advantageous because look here's a new a
and here's a new B and so this a B is
less said that it is all still true
right so I can say I can skip straight
to this line that two times the 1984 is
less than or equal to one no no four
plus two on two squared right again cuz
you've you've formed this pairs in this
way this is still 998 squared do you
agree okay so what I'm going to do is
remember inequalities a little bit
different that's the color I want there
are different two equations I can swap
all of these things out I can swap all
of these things out for something that
is bigger okay so still got my left hand
side over here but what I'm going to do
is see how 998 squared is bigger than
this well if I swap this for 998 squared
then what I've got over here will be
bigger than what I started with does
that make sense so I'm something on a
number for something bigger I'm going to
swap out this number for something
bigger as well like so and this will
also be that now this is going to keep
on going I've got a lot of pairs don't
know how many pairs do I have if you
think back to when we were doing
sequencing series when you've got an
infinite series or sequence we go dot
dot dot it just goes on forever but we
know when it's finite that's why we put
the N term on right which is why I put
this guy here that's the last term in
this bunch of products so you can see it
goes one two three four five six all the
way up to so there are nine hundred and
ninety seven of these does that make
sense of really quickly physics oh no
you got to go to Roll Hall and then
there's this hanger on on the end the
ultimate third wheel except these the
998 wheel okay so there you go all right
so now I'm almost there so close so
close just use some index laws forming
here I'm multiplying 997 times so this
is this multiplied by cell 997 times and
then there's nine nine eight hanging out
one more time
on the end and if you go and double
check on your calculator pretty sure
that that is 1994 yeah you can come in n
to the seventh right and then you've got
one more you've got one more
so therefore the number after 1994 is
1995 which is exactly what you wanted to
prove okay
oh hold on no that's not inclusive
because I actually swapped it out for a
bigger number so make sense